what did you just see you know what you
just saw you just saw my name Gary
Vaynerchuk dot t be available on
godaddy.com now this is what I want to
talk to you about my number one belief
going forward in the future is that you
want to own your name dot com write your
name Christopher Chris Montcalm you want
to own that because it was gonna be your
face your platform for the world no
matter what business or anything you do
you want to own that now many of you
already don't you know you missed it
you're not as lucky as I am because your
name isn't Gary Vaynerchuk and it's that
unique that you can get it your name is
John Smith that screwed up that's tough
I get it so what I'm proposing today I'm
Gary on intercom you don't do my little
tidbit action is for every person you
want to make a play you want to own
brand equity within yourself I highly
recommend that every person goes out and
owns their dot TV because i think has
online video with chores more people
watch television than read books I think
our society's gonna watch a lot of video
I think a lot of people going to go to
video as your platform instead of the
written word and I really believe I
really really believe there you go say
that and I really really believe that
your dot TV is the first extension
besides com that has some sort of vote a
little hit of up a little huh and I
think you want to own that so if you
don't own your main TV that is what you
rush out and go do today and I think
they made sure i think uh go dad he's
pretty cool you can use the the password
diggnation save a couple bucks on it not
sure i think that works so um if you
don't own your name TV that is my little
tidbit for you today start a blog video
on it it's the important extension to
own with your name have a great day have
a great holiday but most importantly
call somebody you love like a grandma or
uncle you haven't talked in a while
that's the real [ __ ] my friends that's
the real [ __ ]